foreign
told me that I'm the reason she's
depressed because
um I won't be here for Christmas I'll be
with my in-laws you are one terrible
daughter Sarah
you know that you know that's nonsense
right yeah but but it hurts I know
[Music]
what's up this is John with Dr John
deloney's show the greatest mental
health and marriage of parenting podcast
ever
talk about everything we walk alongside
you and the wheels are falling off or
they have fallen off and we just figure
out the next right thing to do so thank
you for joining us giving us your most
precious resource which is your time if
you want to be on this show go to John
deloney.com ask ask
or you can give us a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 okay we have a couple of
housekeeping things here this is
important
somebody from Oklahoma I'm not gonna put
your address I'm just gonna hold this
little brown envelope up
sent me
a piece of bubble wrap and a piece of
cardboard and here's all it said
Dr John
we notice you like to use g2s
which tells me right off the bat they're
a pin connoisseur that's what I use the
G2
kind of spooky a little bit a little bit
misery like but I accept very good
says replace the ink in that G2 with
this refill and thank us later Mandy and
Danny go now do it
so I did I opened up my pen I took out
the refill that I didn't know existed
and it's a Schmidt fine liner made in
Germany
and I don't know who you are you
sorcerers
Mandy and Danny but this is the best
freaking pen refill I've ever seen in my
life I feel like my gen my my g2s
got upgraded in a way that I didn't know
was possible it's like you dropped a
Ferrari engine in the middle of like a
Ford Escort
and
you don't have to go to church for the
rest of the Year y'all are good on
everything you have to don't have to
you've done all of your giving for the
Year Mandy and Danny you've changed my
life I literally got on Amazon and
ordered a whole bunch of these because I
feel like I'm a better person now that
I'm writing with the Schmidt insert in
the G2
thank you for loving me more than I love
myself this is really a great gift and
um
yeah I'll just leave it at that Mandy
and Danny you're great human beings and
you're from Oklahoma
who who
that those two could be the same
together I'm super excited I'm super
excited about this
um y'all are great humans uh all right
let's I'll add a whole other thing we're
gonna do but I got too excited about
this I can't tell you guys
I'm not I'm not uh sorry I'll just stop
Kelly's like just move along I can't
tell you how incredible this pin insert
is
and this this is a like a a real life
demonstration about how lame my life is
but man this is awesome all right let's
go to Sarah let's go to Sarah and the OC
Orange County California what's up Sarah
hi Dr John how are you I I was I was
great and now that I got this new insert
for my pen I am incredible and now I'm
talking to you the home of Social
Distortion there in Orange County and I
don't know that things get much better
so it's awesome what's up
um so my mom told me that I'm the reason
she's depressed because
um I won't be here for Christmas I'll be
with my in-laws
you are one terrible daughter Sarah
you know that you know that's no that's
nonsense right
yeah but but it hurts I know
why did she lay that on you in that way
four words
like what if she doesn't get what she
wants
um
give me an example of something she's
told you
she'll call you condescending she'll
call you
um
terrible person she'll call you bad
names all sorts of stuff like that and
it's like in a heat of Rage like like a
red line almost yeah
but then she forgets it like and then
it's over with and as long as she's
gotten out what she wants
then it's like the conversation's over
and then if you bring it up how dare you
hurt her that's fine yeah but then it's
fine the next day of course nothing
happened of course it is
but if you bring it up then how dare you
keep bringing up the past what are you
trying to do
yeah
it's been your whole life
for the most part yeah
okay
I need you to hear me super clear
what's happened to you your entire life
is abuse and it should never have
happened
and I know people are watching this and
they're going to give me grief for
overusing the word abuse but you have
been responsible
for the emotional care of an adult
and an adult that is not that is is
weaponizing her relationship with her
daughter as a way of propping herself up
and that should never ever happen
and I'm sorry that happened to you
I want you to I want you to acknowledge
the depth of this because this has
affected all of your relationships
throughout your life hasn't it
thank you um I did go to therapy for
like five months a couple years ago when
I started doing boundaries my husband
and I are like a United friend
um
he's the one who actually told me
when we first started dating he's like
that's not normal
um
like for someone to yell at you like
that about
numerous different things and everything
and then we did the whole boundaries and
everything
um and it's worked really well but now
it's starting to
seems to slip backwards and she doesn't
like that I have boundaries of course
she doesn't and she says it's me putting
up walls
Hey listen
she has cashed in her votes she gets no
votes no say
she abuses you Sarah no more
okay
and I know that's hard to hear because
since you were a little bitty girl
you've been responsible for making sure
she was okay she wasn't mad and she got
whatever she wanted
yeah okay and so practicing this
because your survival mechanisms have
been to make sure she's okay
so that you could be safe and not get
screamed at or hit or kicked out or
whatever the the the thing of the day
was
that's been taking care of her has been
the way you stayed alive and so
you learning to be whole and well in
your marriage and learning to completely
break this cycle and change your family
tree in a profound way is gonna feel for
a season like you are gonna die it's
gonna feel like you're being over
exposed
because this is how your body's kept
itself safe for so long
so yeah for me if I tell my mom like my
mom
um hey I'm not doing this thing I'm not
gonna be able to make it down and my mom
said that really breaks my heart I was
counting on you coming and
I would I would feel guilty about that
rightfully so I feel guilty that I made
my I broke my mom's heart
and I would also acknowledge her right
to
have her heart broken she's allowed to
do that she's an adult
and I would know my mom's not trying to
hurt me she's trying to tell me that she
really misses me and wants me there
when your mom says
you are making me depressed
and your choices are selfish and
self-centered and you care more about
him and his family than you do your own
Mom after I gave everything up for you
your body is not going to respond like
mine your body's gonna go screaming and
running from for the Hills
right
yeah the only way to heal from this is
to walk directly through the middle of
it that means put up your boundary
and when she
starts firing her weapons feel it
acknowledge it
be be as distant as you can create space
and here's what I mean by that when your
body starts to take off on you after one
of her email rants or one of her text
message rants or one of her phone call
rants
feel your body and as though you're
watching it from a ladder look down at
it and say man it is really trying to
take care of me and protect me
but luckily I'm an adult now and I'm
married to an awesome guy
and we're creating something different
so you don't have to take care of them
anymore because Mom doesn't get a vote
anymore
and it's not gonna just it's not gonna
be a magic switch but you're going to be
practicing this thing as you move on
does that make sense
it does
um there's one we do work at the same um
company so sometimes some of this stuff
who's that you and your mom yeah has
happened there like that that happened
at work what do you what do you all do
what do you forget what she does what do
you do
um I I run the office
but what's I mean what's the
like you're an office manager you're
you're yeah
um I would do everything I can to get a
new job
I would I would create some space it's
time
and the reason I'm telling you that is
is there's a physiological consequence
to what you're doing every day you don't
know it but you're going to work and
your body goes to war
thank you
it is scanning it is 24 7 hyper
vigilance it is making sure Mom's okay
let's don't do this because mom's going
to get mad I need to go in early mom
can't be there so I've got you see what
I'm saying the little machine underneath
your daily life is running hot
if you had one of these whoop straps
that I wear I can guarantee you that
your HRV would be low
I'd be willing to I'd be willing to bet
okay because your body is running hot am
I tell me I'm tell me I'm crazy like
you're an idiot John it's always awesome
except when she gets mad
it it is it's it's awesome unless if she
gets mad I mean she's she's just an
employee too you know what I mean
um and so I'm technically above her yeah
okay all right well yeah so that might
be part of well there comes a moment
when you say I don't care who you are
you don't like we're at a place to work
you can't talk to me like that
yeah or there becomes a moment when you
report her to your supervisor or if you
have the ability to say hey you can't
talk to me like that or you can't work
here
um all of that
is you asserting your right to be well
and your right to not be yelled at in
your right to not be
responsible for the temper tantrums of
other adults whether at the workplace or
whether at home
you know what I mean your mom is making
a lot of choices you cannot be
responsible for her choices to be
miserable it's not your job
yeah she can choose to go have friends
she can choose to oh my daughter's going
to be really happy for her daughter that
she married somebody incredible
and that they get to go spend time with
his family
she should celebrate you and cheer you
on even if she's sad that she's not
getting to spend Thanksgiving with you
that's called being an adult
and then she can decide to have friends
or I have a friends giving we're gonna
have a bunch of wackadus over it at our
house that's what we're doing
Thanksgiving is this week when I'm
recording this
we're gonna have people over my family's
not gonna be here so we're going to have
friends over and they're friends that I
don't know super well and I'm excited to
have them over it's a choice we made to
not just sit at home and be miserable by
ourselves you see what I'm saying
yeah definitely she gets to choose that
and you can't make those choices for her
the only person you can choose for is
you
and here's one thing I want you to be
very careful of okay you mentioned
united front
be very careful about not dumping all of
this responsibility on your husband
okay
okay I want you to practice
the belief that you are worth this
even if that means getting up every
morning and writing it down 10 times
I am worth having a life where I laugh
really hard I am worth having a life
where I love my husband recklessly
I
have I'm worth going to work and not
worrying if Mom's going to be in a bad
mood today
and I want you to begin to practice
those things say them out loud
okay
okay you got it this is the this is
Sarah this is the hard work of breaking
a cycle
God I'm sorry this happened to you
and for those of you listening I know we
have lots of Sensational calls on this
show
the reason I'm so passionate about this
because this is
these are deep sea planted seeds aren't
they Sarah
it like makes you feel guilty
like cutting them but then you you're
you're glad you set the boundaries
but then you feel guilty because you can
tell that they're hurt but it's because
of their own actions yes yes yes
choose guilt over resentment every time
every time
if you don't and let's say you canceled
your Thanksgiving plans and decided to
go like okay I gotta go be with my mom
because she told me I'm the reason she's
depressed so I gotta go with her
and then it happened again
and then happen again
eventually your husband begins to resent
her and you
and you begin begin to resent her
because you do want to go spend time
with your in-laws you like them they're
nice they're fun
yeah I love them so you see what I'm
saying and so you're going to begin to
resent them and then it's hard to come
back
and so let's hold the boundaries up and
if Mom starts to yell at you I want you
to stop and say
I'm not going to allow you to yell at me
today when you're ready to talk like an
adult then I'm happy to talk with you
but I'm not I'm not going to sit here
and be yelled at have a great day and
then hang up the phone
if she sends you a bunch a long wild
text message and you see how long it is
just reply back I'm not going to read
all of this we can talk on the phone
later
see what I'm saying
yeah begin to assert yourself and you're
gonna have to practice asserting because
asserting has got you hurt in the past
and I will say it one more time
parents if you tell your kids you are
making me fill in the blank
you are choosing to participate in their
dysregulation and their distrust for
themselves and for for their inability
to
know where they are in space because
they're too busy making sure you're not
sad or you're not frustrated or you're
not angry you're not raged out that's
not their job they're kids
they're kids
and I mess it up too man the number of
times I've gone back to my son and say
hey I said you made me frustrated you
didn't I chose to be frustrated
because I'm an adult and you don't have
that kind of control over my emotions
and it's hard and something I gotta work
at it's but that's what adults do as we
gotta work at this
putting this crap on your kids man
because they grow up and they get
married and they don't know who and
where they are
it's not right
let's step it up parents
our kids need us we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591
nmlsconsumeraccess.org Equal Housing
lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100
Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs are
for select loan types only not available
in all states or locations
all right we are back it is time
for everybody's segment
nope everybody's favorite segment I am
incredible at this job by the way
everybody's favorite segment facts are
your friends
cue the drum beats
man I wish I could rap this would be a
great time to like hip-hop over this
it would not be great so all right today
back to your friends
man I tell you what the number of people
sliding into the old DMS and sending in
emails I know they weren't
I kill you must slide into a lot of DMS
as much as that's a trigger for you
just move along
okay
so
um man I get a lot of questions emails
calls all of it about seasonal affective
disorder or sad as the nerds say
uh actually the nerds say seasonal
affective disorder the cool kids say sad
so
um
here's what it is all right so if you
back up and and look take a 30 000 foot
view
um it's
the feeling you get it's this Lo it's
this feeling of being low of being
depressed of being underwater if you
will in the fall and into the winter and
all usually through the winter
um sometimes into the spring
um this is uh it has genetics in origin
it has family of origin and origin right
where wherever your lineage comes from
um it all that in all honesty
um if you want to go listen to Dr Andrew
huberman's podcast about it it can go
down a rabbit hole he's way smarter than
me on this stuff
um here's what I want you guys to know
number one it's a For Real shift it is
real okay and it's a down regulation as
the nerds say in mood and it affects
true seasonal affective disorder right
the actual depression affects about five
percent of the population give or take
but I think infinitely more folks
suffer from feel acutely that
down regulation of mood right and here
here when I moved to Tennessee so I was
in West Texas which is about 30 or 45
minutes from one time zone
and I stayed in the same time zone
moving to Tennessee but now I'm in
Nashville and I'm 45 minutes from the
other time zone
and so at five o'clock in in late fall
and into the winter here in Nashville 4
30. it is Pitch Black outside
it is night night night dark
and my first year I moved here I
remember about February feeling like
something was sitting on my chest I
couldn't I couldn't breathe a lot I
thought something was wrong with me I
started thinking I'd taken the wrong job
I thought I just thought I wasn't okay
and then it occurred to me one day I was
walking to work and I was in by the way
I was going to work and it was Pitch
Black I was getting out of work and was
Pitch Black and there was just this gray
that hung over over the city of
Nashville for a couple of months
um it occurred to me oh
growing up in Texas in the South this is
the longest my body has ever gone
without sunlight
I'm gonna have to be really intentional
about
my mood and the things that affect my
mood right so I don't want us to get
caught up in the Diagnostic in the do I
have officially have seasonal affective
disorder or seasonal depression or let's
just talk about how we feel okay
and so I don't know if I had clinical
sad probably not but for the purpose of
the show I just want to continue to
challenge us beyond the diagnosis okay
depression feeling low
into full-blown I can't get out of bed
because I can't breathe right genetics
environment we said all that
um
here's a couple of things I've done over
the past few years and recently that
have made a tremendous difference now I
love the winter here it's Unique and
it's different but I love it
um I did buy and I spent some money on
it okay so this is not cheap I got the
expensive version probably not the
expensive version but I did not go for
the cheapest option
um but I recently bought
um it's a box lamp from I wrote it down
here northern light technology this is a
box light it's about 180 bucks it's
expensive
there's a bunch of them that you can buy
for 25 30 35 bucks that are basically
art lamps right that you draw use them
to draw with or to trace with
um mine has I think 10 000 Lux you can
get them as low as 900 or a thousand I
just turn it on in the morning and I put
it 12 to 14 inches for my face and I
just have my coffee and I do my morning
gratitude journal and stuff in the
morning
um and I just have it on occasionally
I'll glance at it but it has made a
tremendous difference in what I call
like the domino effect and these
dominoes go one way and they can also go
the other way okay
um Dr huberman has done a great job over
the past couple of years pointing out
how critical
light is especially in the morning
um to our eyes into our brain function
and then our overall Downstream
physiology so for years it was important
for me just to get outside in the
morning I didn't realize what a benefit
that was simply because of the sunlight
I thought it was because of the cold
exposure which I'm sure had something to
do that I thought it was because of the
grounding I like to go outside with any
shoes on
but turns out it probably the most
important thing I was doing was getting
sunlight even on cloudy days even on
overcast days
um and when you wake up and it is just
pitch black and I get up super early
having this lamp has been a game changer
for me
um also going outside is a big deal so
here's a couple of so so number one make
it a point to get Bright Lights even if
you just wake up in the morning and turn
the lights on by the way if you wake up
and continue to lay prone late lay down
and just scroll your phone the worst
thing you can do at least open your eyes
and sit up
sit up and turn the lights on and if
you're married and somebody's just
crashed out and if you turn the lights
on they're gonna stab you with the
nearest sharp object then leave the room
and go somewhere where you can sit
straight up and you can turn the lights
on I I even do my meditations after I
have some time in front of this light
just to get me what just to wake me up
and I go back and turn the lights off in
the basement
get light in your eyes get light in your
eyes get light in your eyes morning walk
great bundle up and go for a walk have a
lot whatever it looks like okay
here's
um a common thing that happens and it's
just it's The Dominoes going the other
way
right so you start your morning with
light you start your morning with your
gratitude you start morning with your
exercise your caffeine you're starting a
set of dominoes one way and that one way
is going to be an optimized mind a body
that's up an atom a positive a more
positive attitude a more positive
morning routine
it also goes the other way
so if you wake up in the morning and you
hit snooze and you hit snooze and that
cold and that cold room you feel so good
because you're under warm covers in that
cold room and you just stay in the dark
and stay in the dark and you're in that
there's some technical words for it but
you're in that that I call it that
underwater space we are not fully asleep
but you didn't go back to I mean you can
go back to sleep all the way but you're
not really awake
you're just kind of there and also you
wait until the last possible you pop up
out of your bed and you sprint into the
shower and you take a thousand degree
shower super hot you brush your teeth
and you grab a bar of some sort you run
out the door to go to work
you have just started a Domino's with
your cortisol with your adrenal with
your whole fight or flight system
and you head down you start those
dominoes and then bam by nine o'clock
ten o'clock unless you're got an iron
will you're grabbing
something from the candy Bowl in the
office or somebody shows up with donuts
and you're like I'll have six and then
you're grabbing more coffee and more
coffee and more coffee and then a Red
Bull and then somebody's like hey dude
you like Monster drinks and you're like
no I like my trucks like a regular
person without being 17 inches off the
ground but I'll have a monster you start
that you go down that road
and a common side effect of seasonal
affective disorder and I happen to be of
the opinion that one begets the other
is as the days get shorter
substance abuse increases your drugs of
choice and so people will drink a little
bit more they will grab another drink
and another drink or they'll have us
start smoking again they'll it's just it
just feels like it's right because Cole
let's grab a cigarette whatever it is
go to holidays and then you drink and
then it messes up your sleep and now
you're back in the morning and you don't
want to get out of bed and see what I'm
saying like The Dominoes have gone that
way I call it the the the underwater
effect you just slowly find yourself
under water and then man mid to late
December you're in the holidays and it's
family drama and stuff and you're over
budget
and you just can't get out of bed
right you've just locked it down so
um and by the way you're not exercising
at that point you're just eating
whatever you can get it so it just
starts a cycle so I want to be
intentional on the front end of this
cycle
um here's some things I have found
besides the light okay that keep me from
going down that cycle it's to go the
other direction
um and they are these are not going to
be popular and what I'll tell you is you
get to choose your heart do you want to
have hard miserable short days that are
cold and dark and just
or do you want to have hard days that
you do hard things and it's you are
enjoying these days you get to pick one
both of them are going to be hard okay
and I've done them both and I am
choosing
the optimistic joyful
um hard things to do okay number one I
don't drink during the holidays
I just don't
if I if you do
watch how you feel and make sure you
don't skip your routine the next morning
regardless of how much you have to drink
the night before
I just adds to it compresses an already
devolving mood and I I've just not found
it to be worth it and then it starts
messing up my sleep and it makes it hard
to get up in the morning and then I eat
junk food it just starts a whole set of
dominoes I know holiday parties and I
know holiday family time some of you the
only way to get through holiday time is
with one or two or seven or nine glasses
of wine
be really intentional about cutting back
your alcohol intake if you can't this is
a great time of year to say I'm going to
start a new and get on top of that
um cold water exposure I won't go into
all the nerd stuff about it
whether you're going outside and I went
to Tractor Supply and got a 100 tub and
it's I filled up with water I haven't
done it in a while but I used to do it
every single day
um
it's transformative two or three minutes
and you think you're gonna die
um my son used to get into in there with
me for a couple for for several months
um now I rarely rarely
um take anything other than a cold
shower in the morning and I get my water
comes from a well and from a spring like
out of the out of the side of a mountain
uh outside of a hill and it's cold and
it's it's transformative again in the
morning
um militant about exercising I just
don't miss especially between November
and January unless I'm sick I don't miss
I go do something down there I go to and
then I say down there in my home gym
just have a couple of Weights in my
basement
um don't miss you gotta move your body
some of you don't have any weights
you're not interested in that great go
for a walk if you can't go for a run go
for a walk if you can go for a walk just
go outside and I don't know just walk
around your front yard You Gotta Move
Your Body okay
um and then I count calories this is a
whole Downstream set of drama
um not in a Draconian way or not like in
a uh like I've got a headband on and my
wife's got leg warmers and we're like
doing Jane Fonda and we're like have a
like a menthol cigarette and a tab and
we're like we're gonna count calories
not like that
but I'm intentional about what I'm
eating and how much because it's just so
easy to grab a cookie and then another
cookie and then another cookie and then
let's go ahead and grab this and I'm
gonna put
extra creamer in here I'm gonna get some
more bacon and suddenly I am I'm adding
a thousand calories per day and that
just has an effect on how I feel and how
I move and my overall mood and and and
um there is some
yeah this is kind of give or take I take
vitamin D K2 I get it from Thorn and
remember uh go thorn.com you slash
deloni and you can get 25 off everything
um I do take it I I think the efficacy
is we're still trying to figure that out
but um
meaning I don't know if supplementing
with vitamin D is as important as going
outside and getting Vitamin D naturally
but I'd do it anyway
um and then I'm outside a lot I'm a big
hunter and big Walker um I like to be
outside a lot and so even when it's
freezing freezing freezing cold but
there's just outdoor exposure and sun
and changing temperatures all these
things lift mood
okay
here's an important thing before I wrap
it up depression is very very real and
it's very very dangerous okay holidays
can be a heavy time too
if you find yourself underwater and the
idea of these things I just said like I
can't take a cold shower
I can't get out of bed
I'm starting to have hard conversations
with myself about whether I need to be
here anymore
whether I'm ever gonna get these debts
paid off I'm never gonna be able to stop
drinking or stop eating
and you have Suicidal Thoughts thoughts
about quitting life or you find yourself
looking at pornography again and again
and again and grabbing another drink and
another drink
call somebody
the world would not be better without
you here
and it's very flippant of me to say oh
it's all just a bunch of behavior it is
you can change a lot of it but some of
you are going to be in a statistical
minority of folks who are suffering from
deep depression and you gotta Reach Out
gotta reach out and if you love somebody
who's struggling don't just say oh you
need to exercise I'm gonna turn all the
lights on in the morning not cool
[Music]
model by example lead with love okay
if you find yourself you can't do
anything
make that call
so that seasonal affective disorder
we get it all
thumbs up all right cool we'll be right
back
hey what's up deloney here I know I know
it's the holidays you're super busy and
between all the decorating Christmas
trees and Christmas parties and your
friends drinking too much eggnog family
visits so many family visits it's so
easy to skimp on sleep don't fall into
that trap my friends you've got to take
care of yourself and your mental health
during the holidays and that means
prioritizing sleep sleep is one of the
best things you can do for your mental
health any time of year but especially
right now and for me getting deep
restorative sleep starts with a good
mattress and that's why my family sleeps
on dream Cloud mattresses and right now
dream cloud is running an unbelievable
offer exclusively for my listeners get
25 off any mattress 599 dollars in
accessories that's pillows a mattress
protector and luxury sheets plus an
additional 50 cash discount when you use
promo code deloni so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com
only or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress today
all right we're back let's go to Jack in
Tampa what's up Jack
hey Dr deloney how are you I'm good man
what's up
well uh if you if my memory serves me
right uh these episodes are recorded
about a month before they're dropped
which means this thing will drop right
about Christmas time
so if you don't mind I'd like to wish
you and all the folks at Ramsey
Solutions and all the listeners across
the
Ramsey land here a very merry Christmas
to you and all your families and hope
the uh holidays find you well thank you
so much man and you too hope you guys
have a great Christmas
well
uh so the reason I'm calling
is
um
my uh so I'm
I'm going uh through a divorce I've been
going through it for about two years now
since my wife left me
[Music]
um why don't you leave and
uh we'll um
you're going to make me jump to my
secondary problem very quickly here
um usually the secondary problem is
hidden behind a pretend first problem
[Laughter]
well uh
I don't know why my wife left me for
sure
um why has she told you she left you
boy you got cameras somewhere
um
nope just been doing this a long time
and you have a very evasive Cadence
why did you leave me she told you very
directly and you don't like what she
said or you don't want to believe it why
did she tell you she left you actually
it's because I I can't remember why
um so
uh I have a problem with blocking out
I guess uncomfortable things so I've
asked her twice
and the first time I don't remember
anything about what she said
and the second time I asked her I tried
really hard to concentrate on what she
was telling me
and
um my brain took me to a
different place I completely tuned her
out
um like I just like she was talking
through a pillow like she was talking
but I wasn't able to focus on anything
she was saying
and uh
when did this start
I'm not sure
um I didn't realize it was really a
problem
until that happened and then
I've been staying with my little sister
through this divorce process and we were
talking about some things that happened
in our childhood when we were teenagers
and she's was telling me about something
that happened to her and I was there and
she says oh but you probably don't
remember because you're like Mom you
forget things
that are uncomfortable which
I have no idea what she means about my
mom I got hung up on the whole me thing
so that's the first that was the first
time you'd ever heard that
yeah from somebody else and so you have
she disclosed that
like you were there when abuse happened
or family trauma happened but you just
block it out like always and because
nothing happened
and that was the first you'd ever heard
of that
yeah yes and no it was the first
we had some things happen in our what
early early childhood
so let me let me uh absent um a brain
tumor
or absent
um some significant uh brain lesions or
absence some horrific childhood trauma
you're gonna have to get real Direct
because there's a vagueness to how how
you how you just interact does that make
sense
yeah and it's a protective measure and I
understand it and it makes complete
sense
but it becomes self-reinforcing and so
the healing here is directly through the
middle of it so like what are the things
that happen as when you were a kid that
you that you can remember that you know
about
nobody wants to hear a grown man cry on
Christmas
um
Hey listen here's the deal I love you
and I don't
I can hear it on you
but I want how old are you
32. okay I want you to be very honest
with yourself about how this sort of
evasiveness
on the truth and the stories that you
were born into and that happened to you
what that is what that has given you
it's giving you a lot of Heartache
and so here's what I'm offering you an
opportunity to try to practice something
different
which is let's be very direct
what happened
uh if you don't Hey listen if you don't
want to that's okay I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna bully you into it I'm not
gonna brow beat you
but I I do want you to know healing will
be going right through the middle of
this and you'll probably need a very
skilled trauma counselor and I would
recommend if you were my friend I'd
recommend that you go get a CT scan to
make sure you don't have some sort of
uh
challenges with the with you with your
physical brain but memory and Trauma and
anxiety all that stuff is wound together
in a pretty remarkable way
okay it's all that stuff is really
tightly abraded together and so if you
got problems with memory and you got
problems with family trauma
that's a brain trying to take care of
you
okay yeah that that that's um
that's why I wasn't going to really
address it because I thought maybe it
wasn't that big of a deal if I just
don't remember bad things so incorrect
that's all because your heart remembers
and your brain remembers and your body
remembers
the frontal lobe part the part that just
lets you go on about your day and check
the who won the game and making sure you
get the TPS reports turned in
um that can just go about its day
but your body keeps the score as
vanderkok says and it is revving and
revving and revving and if you've looked
at the aces score the adverse childhood
experiences score it's a scale of one to
ten I want you to Google it after this
it's called Aces there's a million of um
sites you can go to but it's just a 10
question test
the higher your Aces score
five six I think four is when it starts
really changing but six seven and eight
things that happen to you in your
childhood become predictive of strokes
and heart attacks and Cancers and
dementia and other things
because your body is at War
okay and so it feels like just
pretending none of this happened
is the way forward and by the way
replaying it all is not part of
everybody's healing Journey either it's
not like you're gonna have to sit down
and just like hit rewind on all the
videotapes and start again
but you're gonna have to make peace with
what happened
and you're going to have to begin
practicing being present with hard
conversations in the now
yeah right
yeah that that was going to be my next
question is can you even really fix yes
I mean well you're not you're not broken
your brain is working perfectly
so I don't want you to think you're
broken
your brain experience some stuff
right
yeah some evil craziness
and so it has learned
the best way is that we unplug
and we will plug back in when the threat
has passed
and so you're not broken there's nothing
to fix can you be healed yes I believe
with all my heart you can
there's too many incredible advancements
right now and
all kind of trauma therapies and
different trauma therapy techniques and
some of the map stuff with some of the
psychedelics with people who knows
there's too many too much stuff out
there ketamine therapists too many
therapies out there that are working
just doing miraculous things when done
with a trained provider
so yes I have every bit of confidence
uh
so
when uh
me and my uh sisters were
very little
um
I was like
I want to say it was between the ages of
three and six I want to say I was in
kindergarten when my parents finally
took us away
God I can't uh hey don't let's just stop
right there okay
here's what's important about what you
just did
you provided a GPS pin you know where
right
yeah you know where
and
um your brain throws a curtain up and
it'll allow you to dig back to that
curtain I'm gonna recommend you don't go
through that curtain by yourself right
now okay
okay
but I am going to recommend because I
love you you're going to care about you
I want you to call somebody
as a Christmas gift to yourself man
you've been doing this for 30 years
it's exhausting right
yeah
did you love your wife
a lot yeah it hurts
and my guess is she loved you too and
she just went as far as she could go
right
I I don't know I don't know that's what
I'm guessing all right
yeah okay
are you ready to be well and healed
yeah yeah I think so what's the
hesitation man
you ever think something about yourself
but
you'd call yourself all the time but
it's wrong
once you can
you can't stop thinking that way about
yourself so
Rhys actually abused as a kid
oh God
I I uh just just yes yes or no though
let me say it this way the words you are
using are very
uh common among people who were sexually
abused as young children
foreign
okay
not saying you were not putting that
into your head if that's not the case
that's not the case but the words you're
using tell me that you as a young child
suffered terribly
okay I um yeah I mean I I don't I only
know what I was told okay so all right
let's don't go into there on this call
okay let's keep this let's keep this um
where it needs to be until you've got a
professional in the room with you okay
okay are you suicidal in any way
no no I I'm not uh suicidal I just okay
do you work do you have a job
no I have quite a bit of work um yeah I
work um what do you do dude
uh
uh well
I work uh full time as a truck driver
and then I'm I'll work a secondary job
part-time on the weekends as uh working
in a warehouse
and uh students you're not scared of
hard work right
no no I I've scared of sleep apparently
um
just uh just working um and doing a
school at night just
trying to get my finances in line and um
uh my divorce is pretty well
buttoned up just got the
um hearing coming down the line and uh
to have a judge sign off on everything
and there's a custody agreement I'll
have 50 50 custody with my
a little girl uh but contingent on I
have to move to within 50 miles of my
wife and she lives in a bit of a
uh expensive area so I gotta okay
um I'm just trying to get everything in
line to be able to do that be there for
my
that's my daughter which is which is the
uh the point of this call is I just
don't want to screw up my kid with the
um
the the junk that's uh that's my life so
just have you um are you abusive
uh no not that I'm aware of nope that's
not the question I asked you is the
answer yes or no are you abusive
uh no I'm not abusive put a period at
the end of that sentence
one of the Hallmarks of childhood abuse
is that everything has a dot dot dot at
the end of it because you're never quite
sure where it's coming from because the
people that were supposed to keep you
safe the adults in your life are the
ones that hurt you
and so everything is a uh I think I I
don't no you don't abuse your daughter
right
right stand on that
for the first time since she was born
stand on that
you're not afraid of hard work are you
earning a good paycheck
a couple of good Pages yes you are
you're a good dad
okay stand on that do you have some
skills to learn abso freaking lutely you
do we all do
yeah do you have a lot of healing to do
absolutely
foreign
you're stepping in the right direction
okay I wish you wish it hadn't taken a
divorce to get your attention here we
are okay here we are
yeah the only thing you can do from this
point forward is decide what happens
next
you can't go back and edit what happened
when you were a kid
you can't go back and edit the kind of
husband you were or we're not
you can just aside from this point
forward what am I going to do
yeah right
all right and so you're gonna have to
practice
putting a period at the end of your
sentences
okay that's hard
because those got you hurt man
I can't tell you enough you have you
cannot do this by yourself you're gonna
have to call a trauma counselor in your
area Okay do you promise you'll do that
what is what what will happen
if they're a good trauma therapist they
will sit down with you and they will
walk you through how your body responds
in the present to things that happened
in the past
and it will be you will learn some
skills on how to regulate your body when
it starts to leave a conversation you
will learn skills to stay present in
that conversation even if it's a
conversation that says if you don't fix
a b and c I'm going to divorce you
or I'm filing for divorce from you and
you say what happened and then all of a
sudden your body's like Hey we're not
sitting around for this because the last
time we sat around for this when you
were seven or you were three
the other stuff happened so we're out
and you will learn skills to stay
present
and a good trauma therapist will not
drag you through every memory of the
past and make you dredge up the past or
some pretty damning research about
that that could be re-traumatized that's
not the point the point is
how can I take ownership of my body in
the present
that's the goal and some of that does
have some revisiting that happens but
not in the Gory graphics and all that
okay
okay
but what we're looking for here is
peace
and you have never had that
let me describe no let me describe it
can you imagine it being nine o'clock
and you laughing and deciding huh
I could either go to bed
and crash or I can just watch a movie
and you just deciding that not because
you have to because you get to and then
you wake up in the morning and you
decide I think I want to have coffee not
because I have to have chemicals to prop
me up but just cuz
yeah can you imagine dating somebody and
telling a joke and they don't laugh very
hard
and you don't instantly go into a shame
spiral because you're the stupidest
person ever and you're an idiot you just
go like that was a dumb joke you know
what I mean
or your boss comes in and says your
butt's gonna go do this and you say I
I'm actually I'm not have a great day
I've taken care of my finances I'm good
to go I'm going to be at a place where
I'm respected
or it's that guy cut you off in your car
and you don't go to insta rage black
outrage you just let him over you just
nod and be like all right dude in a
square Kia go about your day
peace
you tip that waitress at Waffle House a
hundred bucks on Christmas Day because
you can
because she doesn't want to be working
there on Christmas day but she has to
and you get to on like that's peace man
peace and you've never had that because
your body's been trying to defend you
since you were three
from the people that should have taken
the best care of you
yeah okay that's what I'm talking about
and then your daughter is gonna feel
that connectivity and there's not going
to be a react like a nuclear reactor
she's going to be in the presence of a
dad who's safe
not who says all the right things no Dad
does and not who doesn't say dumb things
and mess up all dads do but a dad whose
presence is
that guy somebody I can anchor into
yeah right
right does that sound good
that sounds
that sounds uh it's a fairy tale right
yeah it's a fairy tale yeah okay so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give
you
um a copy of my book own your past
change your future I want you to read it
and I'll also send you
um a digital copy so you can listen to
it if you're not a reader you can let's
do it while you're driving okay
and the whole book is about making peace
with
these things happen to me whatever these
things happen to be
and then that terrifying question what
do I do next
and the second thing is in exchange for
sending you the book and both versions
of that book you my friend are going to
fulfill your promise and call a trauma
counselor today
you're gonna call somebody today and
you're gonna make an appointment today
so by the time Christmas rolls around
you've had one two maybe three sessions
with them let them know I'm scared I
don't trust you I don't trust adults
don't trust any of this
and not so great have a seat
would you like some tea
and now my brothers were healing's gonna
start
and at some point you'll say sorry to
your wife when the lights come on
and at some point she may see you and
say oh my God
there he is
and your daughter's gonna want to be
around more and more and more and more
because
and make no mistake my man this is gonna
be a hard hard journey
and make no mistake my friend
you're worth every step of the way
thank you for calling and trusting me
man
I'm grateful for you we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back um during the
break we're also going to give our
friend Jack let me talk about getting
his finances squared up and
um
I'm honored to work here at the Ramsey
Solutions office we're for 30 years
we've helped people get out of debt and
so I'm gonna send him a copy of uh our
one year subscription to Financial Peace
where he can take all the classes and
get a good game plan together and the
every dollar app that he can actually
use and track his spending if you're
thinking about changing the way you
spend your money what you do way
finances have taken over your life in a
negative and hard way go to
ramseysolutions.com and it's been
transformative for my life it's been
transformative for millions of people
across the country me and my wife and
our kids we just our lives are different
because of the program so I can't
recommend it enough as we wrap up
today's show
The Mamas and the Papas men
California Dreaming I think everybody's
dreaming of leaving California
I think it's more the weather yes all
the leaves are brown and the sky is gray
I've been for a walk on a Winter's day
uh seasonal affective disorder I'd be
safe and warm if I was in L.A
it'd be warm California Dreaming on such
a Winter's day stopped into a church I
passed along the way I got done on my
knees to pray you know the preacher
lights the coals he knows I'm gonna stay
California Dreaming on such a Winter's
day
or just get a light box that'll work too
love you guys see you soon